last question today's from nico nico
wrote in and said hey David what's the
most unrealistic Democratic campaign
promise of 2020 so far obviously Donald
Trump all along was making unrealistic
campaign promises but what are
unrealistic ones from the left so
there's two ways to answer this question
there's the micro answer and there's the
macro answer if you want to play the
micro of specific policy there are lots
of policies that are unrealistic in the
sense that they ignore that you would
need as president both the House and
Senate to be democratically controlled
in order to make them a reality almost
guaranteed okay so Medicare for all for
example how do you do Medicare for all
without control of the Senate in 2020
yes it's possible in the hypothetical
sense it's extraordinarily unlikely
there's certain infrastructure stuff
that's not realistic in terms of its
political viability without control of
the House and Senate and you have to
understand that we have many examples
even with control by the same party of
the White House the house in the Senate
it's still hard to do stuff universal
background checks when Barack Obama was
in the White House and controlled the
House and Senate 90% support for that
from the American public still couldn't
get it done gun lobby significantly to
blame there but the point is there are
lots of policies that are effectively
non-starters if you don't control the
White House the Senate and the House of
Representatives but that's the micro I
think them this question is more
interestingly addressed at the macro
level the most unrealistic meta or macro
promise is bipartisanship everybody pays
lip service to bipartisanship I know how
to work with the other side I have a
long history of drafting and sponsoring
legislation with people from the other
side of the aisle I would work together
in ways that other candidates aren't
able to I don't think it's a bad idea
it's just completely unrealistic the
last 30 years of increased polarization
have shown us this I did a story on the
Monday show talking about how Donald
Trump is in practice just a symptom of
the problem which has been the rise in
reactionary politics from the right for
the last 20 to 30 years depending on it
how you want to measure it Republic
won't even call out Trump for relatively
minor things you're not going to get
real bipartisanship in this environment
there's no upside to even trying to get
bipartisanship the way our political
system is designed and you actually risk
your own party turning against you if
you start working with the other side so
I'm not saying I don't want
bipartisanship I'm not saying that the
people promising it are straight-up
lying or don't want it themselves what
I'm telling you is that if you ask me
what's the most unrealistic promise we
hear from Democratic candidates is that
they are going to be able to work with
Republicans if they are elected
Republicans who likely will control the
Senate after 2020 and get stuff done
they will have to get stuff done despite
Republicans I would love to hear them
just say that and that's the most
unrealistic promise that we're hearing
that's it for today we've got a great
bonus show keep sending in questions for
next week become a member or a patron to
get instant access to the bonus show WWE
at medCom
or patreon.com slash david pakman show